I'm very excited to announce that Megan
and myself had a baby boy early this
morning a very healthy boy it's hard to
believe it's been almost a year since
Megan Merkel and Harry welcomed their
first son it's magic it's pretty amazing
I mean I have the two best guys in the
world
now at 11 months old Archie Windsor
seems to be taking the world by storm I
spoke to someone who had been sent a
video of Archie a few weeks back he said
that he is super cute and really really
happy little boy he's burbling and and
and sort of desperate to to talk but
certainly already mastered cruising and
is well on his way to walking he may
even be walking already but I was told
very cute very very happy and very
confident little boy Oh
[Music]
last month the Sussex is officially said
goodbye to Royal Life and their
temporary abode on Canada's Vancouver
Island relocating to Megan's hometown of
Los Angeles we believe that there in
Malibu and there is talk that they're
renting an ocean facing Villa wherever
they are they're obviously keeping a low
profile and we understand they're around
not acceptable sadly it doesn't sound
like Archie's been able to see grandma
Dorie adjust yet like the rest of us the
Sussex is our practicing social
distancing my understanding is that
they've been keeping in touch through
you know through social media not
actually seeing each other in person
which must be incredibly hard for Megan
being so close to her mother you know
just a matter of miles away and equally
difficult one would imagine for Doria
because she won't have been able to seen
Archie bird's-eye I am told by reliable
sources that they're taking social
distancing and the government guidelines
very seriously indeed little Archie
turns one on May 6 and asked for how
Megan and Harry plan to celebrate we're
told they probably had to scrap their
original plans of course a big question
mark over how they will celebrate it
because there is every chance that that
we may so be in lockdown they may not be
able to throw and the first birthday
party that they have probably already
planned I think it really is just a case
as with everything at the moment of
having to wait and see
Queen Elizabeth also has a birthday
coming up on April 24th the Sussex is
were scheduled to return to London for
her
public trooping the colour celebration
in June but of course that's been
cancelled too so the first time in
history
and we have been told that trooping the
colour has been cancelled but even
though Megan and Harry are stuck at home
it doesn't sound like they're phoning it
in - just Netflix and chill this isn't a
couple like to sit still and do nothing
in fact I'm told they are really quite
busy I mean of course they're settling
into a new home BB getting Archie
settled into a routine and but you know
there are hard at work hard at work on
their new nonprofit charity of course
earlier this week the Duke and Duchess
confirmed that it would be named arch
well after the news leaked ahead of
schedule I was told that the couple were
not planning to release the new name of
their foundation art well and for for a
couple of weeks or certainly until at
least that this spotlight was not on the
corona pandemic but they were picked to
the post by British newspaper who
managed to obtain documents that they
had filed in the US last month trademark
in copywriting and the name arch well
and I think they they really felt that
they didn't want to load a speculation
out there they want the focus to be on
the corona virus pandemic and I was told
that they personally felt quite awkward
and that they've been forced into making
a statement about something they weren't
quite ready to share with the world
[Music]